this is the new Power Shot g1x from
Canon it's a new camera that debuted
here at CES it's a compact camera you
can carry it around with you pretty much
anywhere but unlike the other G cameras
like the G 12 which is very popular this
one is a much higher performer the image
sensor inside of it is a full 6 times
larger than the other powershot cameras
in the G line also it uses the new digit
5 processor which is a much faster chip
it's especially recommended if you'd
like to shoot video because it could
shoot high def video but unlike some of
the other Canon cameras the zoom and the
autofocus work while you're shooting
video which is really important now the
G 12 is not going away that's a $500
camera and it's still an excellent
camera and it's still a big hit this one
the G 1 X is going to be available in
February and it's going to be $800 so
it's a higher performer camera for the
more serious photographer I would
recommend this camera if you're looking
for something that has the performance
of the DSLR but you're not really quite
ready to go down the DSLR road with all
the bulk in the expense of the lenses
because it's a very solid performing
camera and it performs almost as well as
a DSLR but it's only eight hundred bucks
and it's much more portable